all right it's time to talk about hockey
and what a night last night for the
vegas golden knights
didn't look good early but the knights
roared back 8 news now sports director
chris matthews is in st
paul this morning with a look back at
the action well good morning las vegas
what a game here at the xl energy center
game three was a thriller vegas falls
behind o2 that looked really terrible in
that first period
marc-andre fleury giving up a pair of
goals almost three one was challenged
and overturned so it was two nothing
after one but in the second and third
periods the vegas gold knights come to
life
and their transition offense led to
defense the knights only allowed the
wild five shots on goal in the second
four in the third they come away with a
5-2 win and so now they lead the series
two games to one clearly putting the
pressure
back on minnesota really it's a must-win
game for minnesota coming up on saturday
so a big big night captain stone
with two goals in the game o'reilly
smith scored a goal
brown scored a goal it was a lot of fun
for vegas golden knights fence how about
at the very end
where alex petrangelo keeps the puck out
of the net right there so
a throwing time for the vegas golden
knights and the fans as they go up 2-1
in this series of course
we'll have much more for you today as
the knights will hold an optional skate
we'll see how many
actually come out and skate they're a
little bit tired after this one so it's
going to be
an exciting couple of days for the vegas
school nights we'll bring it all to you
throughout the day
much more on the vegas golden knights
reporting inside the excel energy center
chris matthews eight sports now back to
you guys
all right chris well so as you mentioned
the knights now have a 2-1 series lead
over minnesota in the first round
match-up
now game four saturday evening in
minnesota and then back here in vegas
monday night for game five game six will
be back
in minnesota on wednesday if necessary
game seven will be back here
a week from today in las vegas